well when i came in in 2006 they were in
the middle of putting together a new
redesign of the site and I help them
finish that off and get that launched
and since that time it's you know early
2010 now for for almost four years we've
been sort of relentlessly revising bits
and pieces of the site adding new
functionality to it manipulating it here
and there to respond to different user
needs different you know business
criteria and so forth so i think that
the change has been significant though
very very incrementally paste
for the very fact that it's a different
kind of medium altogether it's just like
yes occasionally you'll see a magazine
like I don't know or these days a
website like TMZ translated to a
television show and it's you know by is
very nature it has to be reimagined or
the new medium it has to be designed or
or thought we thought in a way that's
appropriate to the new medium and that's
the case going between print and web or
print and any kind of digital medium I
think the thing about the Internet is
that it has such has so many so many
characteristics that can be easily
construed to be you know similar or
almost identical to print that it can be
misleading you can think well you just
treat it the way you treat print you're
dealing with pages you're doing with
type you're doing with um you know more
or less static layout elements and turns
out that's not really the case I think
the key difference between the web and
and print medium is on the web or in any
digital medium you're dealing with this
added element of behavior things have a
behavior online whereas in in print that
there's a single canonical expression
for them but online everything responds
to different criteria or or has inherent
states to it based on on that criteria
so you have to design that in a
different way it's completely different
dynamic even though it may look similar
well if you look at the front page of
the
mission there is a very specific
discrete set of stories that are applied
there and you can more or less expect
the print reader to absorb the stories
that that you have on on that front page
in in the same kind of order and more or
less the same kind of fashion on the web
you really have no idea how they're
going to access the the stories that you
had that you've designated to be the
lead stories for the day they could come
in through search they could come in
through a blog they could you know come
in through a news reader they may never
see the the homepage as we've designed
it they may actually bypass it entirely
go directly to the article so all of
these things really play into how you
think about the the overall user
experience in the design that you have
to design a story that might appear on
the front page of the newspaper for the
website you'll have to design it in such
a way that it can be self-contained that
it makes sense if you never hit the
front page of it you know our editors
actually spend a pretty decent amount of
effort retooling rewriting headlines so
that they make sense to somebody who
comes in digitally because oftentimes
headlines in print are meant to sit next
to other headlines and sort of benefit
from that context and we don't know you
don't always have that you know our
articles also online will change based
on the the platform the technology that
people are using to view them so they
may see things differently in one
browser on one operating system and and
very differently on another browser or
even another different kind of device so
we have to have to think about the
things that we designed to make sure
that they apply appropriately to the
very different states that they might be
encountered in
I wouldn't say that it's obviously I
think you still I think more than the
people get give print credit for you
know people still turn to the print
edition as the canonical expression of
what the time said that day it's it's
it's the paper of record and the record
for now anyway you know is most official
in print and so you know the work that
the designers put into crafting a really
unique and powerful I think very very
effective presentation every day I think
is is really important i think if you
took away all the designers and sort of
automated the process tomorrow i think
the the end result would be really
really just satisfying and and
disturbing to a lot of people so i think
there's a lot of value that print
designers ask now you know how long you
know that kind of value that they create
will you know will be welcome in the
marketplace that's that's really
difficult to say I think the economic
pressures are pretty serious